welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question in the show that gives
you too much information about how to
clean up any mess without leaving a
trace that's right your mother will
never know that you broke a lamp that's
been passed down in your family for
generations all you have to do is enlist
the help of several government agencies
and pass a few laws through congress
easy peasy getting things through crime
it's always super easy there's no
problems though lies right through
congress flies right through it's like
there's soap on the ground it's just
like whoa
um my name is mt and i'm here today with
offspring producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt i definitely
broke a family heirloom and never told
my mom about it but she must know by now
she must have figured it out uh and just
took pity on me mom if you're watching
this i'm so sorry brandon's mom if
you're watching this he didn't do it um
we should keep up the illusion because
uh
it's been this long
he didn't do it all right i saw him
we were we're watching iron man together
uh let's don't even worry about it mt's
my lawyer he's a very good lawyer what's
our big question for today brandon well
mt with the disillusion of shield in the
mcu following the revelation had been
infiltrated and influenced by agents of
hydra whoops whoopsie-doopsie did i land
nazis in my government agency
but they they took down shield so now
we've really lacked a centralized
federal force to oversee superhuman
activities we got to keep those heroes
in check right so yeah the sword is on
the rise for sure but their concerns
appear to be more omega-level and less
like data right you know they're not
they're not busting stuff on the streets
they're worried about putting robots
back together and hanging out in space
and flip-flops and uh drinking mai tais
uh but it all leads us to this week's
big question how does the dodc work
within the us government of the mcu um
okay the department of damage control
all right yeah we've seen a lot of the
department of damage control better
known as the dodc in the mcu lately most
notably agent p
cleary was shown in both spiderman away
home and miss marvel investigating the
abilities and activities of both peter
parker and kamala khan but the odc has
been in the mcu for much longer than
that in fact it's been there since the
very beginning of the mcu way back
during the events of the first ironman
film but what exactly does the
department control and how much power do
they actually have and how have they
changed over the years let's see if we
can try and figure all of that out
together my beautiful nerd babies shall
we do it shall we i think we should do
it let's go do it let's do it let's go
back
back to the beginning
see that that was a some uh hillary
hillary duff was that hillary though i
think it's really tough um
the song second my cranium i don't
i don't own all of hillary duff's albums
i don't have a hillary duff shrine under
my bed what the department of damage
control was originally not its own
autonomous federal department in fact it
started as just a team within shield
agent phil coulson first references the
team during the ironman film set in
2009. and apparently the damage control
team wasn't even that much of a secret
because before tony's now infamous i am
iron man press conference you can see on
a tv a news crawl mentioned that the
damage control officials would be
issuing a full report on the duel of los
angeles within a few days so as much
which is crazy i never knew i never knew
that that battle between iron man and
iron monger had like an official name
the duel of los angeles i mean we talked
about the battle of new york all the
time the duel of los angeles is where it
all began
i didn't know it was official i feel
yeah i mean like if all this crazy stuff
is going to happen in the mcu i feel
like every event has like a crazy name
it's like the duel of los angeles the
great
battle of where anthony died
the san francisco ant chronicles right
when they're going through the streets
or whatever but i if if you guys haven't
seen the first iron man in a long time
go back and watch it again it's crazy
how much gets set up in that first movie
and they had no idea what was coming
they didn't even know they threw samuel
jackson at the end as like a joke like
yeah we'll just give him a little bit i
mean he says he says the avengers
initiat initiative which is a little
strange it's crazy how much gets set up
in that and yeah it's like almost a
throwaway line that coulson has and they
put that little thing on the news crawl
uh you know there's so many weird little
things hidden in that movie that come
back later in the mcu it's crazy it's
great even a roxon mention uh which is
gonna sure become huge in the next few
years oh yeah bro if roxanne does not
show up in thor love and thunder i will
be shocked because like okay my god look
at that asgardians are all about energy
and like they have all that bifrost
energy okay like and also i feel like
king valkyrie has access to the odin
force which the roxon probably wants a
little bit of it's like
let me get some of that um so yeah we're
definitely gonna see roxanne and i yeah
i do love how kevin feige was thinking a
million steps ahead from the jump from
the first film he was like let's set up
shield that's enough damage control
let's get freaking samuel jackson with
his beautiful bald head
at the end of the movie it's gonna oh
man like he is the ultimate 4d chess
master oh he is and such a fanboy i mean
sam raimi talked about during the
spider-man movies he was like let's get
wolverine in here let's uh let's throw
in some other characters i mean they
have the doctor strange mention in
spider-man like he was trying so hard to
get this stuff in these movies he's like
very smart about it all and yeah you're
right mt we know roxanne is gonna be in
big in the future right we saw that in
loki they're they're a big part of
earth's culture in the future they
become they become like big so
they gotta show up soon they gotta show
up soon so yeah so as much as shield
might have been a secret organization at
the time their damage control team was
not that much of a secret it seemed i
think they were kind of like a known
government agency but no one knew what
they really did they just had like very
high level clearance they'd roll into
town and be like very mysterious about
it like we saw that in thor right they
kind of roll into new mexico and
everyone's like who are these guys like
they must be somewhat known within the
universe already even before all this
superhuman stuff starts happening
well like we do know that um you know
captain marvel was on the scene in the
90s and so like she started
making some damage at the time so maybe
you have to marble make it something it
was
making a little bit of damage that
blockbuster definitely needed a damage
control team um for sure well shield
certainly existed right because samuel
or uh nick fury was working for shield
and it was probably like hold over from
uh you know we know that it's a hold
over from what the ssr was right and
they knew way back in the day that there
were things like the tesseract and uh
you know there were powerful forces out
there so shield was always around kind
of operating at this high level and
people knew about them i'm sure like
other government agencies knew about
shield i'm sure i'm sure plenty of
senators always knew because they were
like where's all this money going why do
we need shield and they'd take a couple
of them to an office and be like there's
aliens out there
don't ask questions
much like area 51 release the aliens let
them out
free the aliens what are you doing jesus
christ aliens i'm gonna i'm gonna pluto
run at that wall and get those aliens
out of area 51. it's the only way to
dodge the bullets brandon the naruto
it's the only way so editors please edit
brandon naruto running please
i'll send you my home footage of it
it wouldn't be long before this damage
control team became more powerful
because in 2012 following the chitauri
attack on new york in the first avengers
film we learn that the department of
damage control now exists when director
ho comes in to stop adrian's tomb's crew
from cleaning up after the battle of new
york and she references executive order
396b as placing all cleanup operations
falling under the dodc jurisdiction and
creates a new villain in the process
yeah way to go lady without the
department of damage control we wouldn't
have vulture and the tinkerer and
the shocker one and shocker too
ah my guys we got a whole crew here we
got families you can't you can't take
this job away from us we need this job
we have a job that was a little john
travolta i think that was a little uh
welcome back connor yo mr gotta we need
this job all these john
oh come on come on spiderman i need this
job come on
he opens the door and it's john travolta
but he's peter's just as shocked as john
travolta that he's he's vulture it's
like oh my god it's john travolta i mean
john travolta kind of is vulture he's a
pilot he knows how to fly he's flying up
there in the sky right now we never know
where he's gonna he's got end of grease
he went right into the sky
he flew a car into the stage he's got a
runway that leads right to his house
like he can he could leave his front
door get on his plane and fly somewhere
he is the vulture yo we got he's bald
now he's bald empty he's become the
vulture we gotta stop he's slowly
becoming he's he's assembling a team
oh my gosh
we'll crack the case and this show shows
us that the dodc falls under the
executive branch of the government and
if you need a civics refresher our us
government has three branches the
judicial branch which covers courts it
evaluates laws the legislative branch
which covers congress and makes the laws
and the executive branch which covers
the president their cabinet and most of
the federal agencies tasked with
carrying out the laws and that's how the
government works
and they all get along and there's no
problems and they treat them there's
never any problems at all
also so if the dodc is an executive
agency it means it was set up by the
president of the united states and then
at some point the president can ask
congress to pass some laws to give the
dodc some authority
and it's probably very similar to how
the department of homeland security was
set up in our world because following
the events of september 11th president
bush created the office of homeland
security to coordinate a comprehensive
national strategy then congress passed
the aviation and transportation security
act which formerly turned the department
of homeland security into a
cabinet-level department mta it created
the tsa and hasn't that been great for
all of us taking our shoes off at the
end of course putting all of our liquids
into the tiny little bottles never
taking nail files onto an airplane ever
again it's been great no problem dude
like i have to go on the internet to see
uh feet now i don't have to i just have
to go to the tsa line and wait for
someone to take their shoes
there's nothing more
disrespectful than that little
the benches after the tsa where
everyone's tucking their shirt back in
putting their belts and shoes on
what's happened to us
in my day you used to be able to walk
right up to the airplane
you can kiss your loved ones goodbye
right on the tarmac they'd let you go in
and shake the pilot's hand he could push
all the buttons on the plane he didn't
care you could sit on the outside of the
plane if you wanted to we all inflated
our vest inside the plane and put on the
oxygen mask and had a party you could
eat steak on a plane with knives and
forks it was great but you are right mt
like the uh the government creates these
depart like the president can create a
department uh and then like congress can
like vote to give that department like
power and then you know the president
has a cabinet right we're all familiar
with the cabinet uh and
only two people on the cabinet serve at
the discretion of the president the rest
he has to like nominate someone and they
get like approved by the senate to like
be on the cabinet right so it's kind of
a mix of while like most of the
departments our executives
fall under the executive branch they get
their laws and their power from the
legislative branch that's how like a
bicameral government works that's how we
checks and balances baby uh that's how
it all works but it is interesting to
think because within the mcu
they kind of had the same history as
america right and then president ellis
became the 45th president uh within the
mcu meaning obama was the 44th president
in the mcu and i think the way this
lines up obama set up the department of
uh damage control uh he kind of made
them autonomous because he would have
been president during
the attack on new york uh when all this
happened he still would have been
president because we know ellis is
president during the events of like iron
man 3 uh and during a lot of the agents
of shield stuff but i'm pretty sure
obama created the department of damage
control but he sets up the dodc and then
he's like i'm done goodbye you're on
your own and then ellis takes over and
he's done a okay job i don't know i
don't know he's not not been the best
president for the empire i mean he had a
super villain of a vice president um who
got who he got him kidnapped in iron man
3. so uh i don't know about that happens
basically just another day at the office
it happens i mean like while the vice
president had a daughter that needed
help from the extremist project so i
guess it makes sense or granddaughter i
don't know what happens hey spiro agnew
tried to get nixon kidnapped it's okay
it's okay
man is flawed you know it has happens
sometimes it happens
a big old whoopsie just like having [ __ ]
in your whole ass shield but yeah it
would make sense that following an alien
attack on u.s soil that the president
and the us government would want to have
more control and authority especially
over any leftover alien technology and
since shield has failed to stop it it's
likely the executive branch in congress
wanted more oversight into how the
activities of superhumans would be
handled and while they handled the big
jobs like cleaning up after the battle
of new york and they also showed up in
agents of shield to clean up after an
attack by the watchdogs in naperville
illinois and it was probably smart the
government separated the damage control
from shield because as we learned in
captain america winter soldier shield
was actually infested with hydra whoops
don't don't do that
whoever was the hirer uh whoever did the
job hiring for a shield immediately
needs to get fired you're done
you're done or it's probably hydra
themselves i mean hr hr might have been
hydra that's the problem
that's what the h stands for in hr hydra
recruiting
hr yeah um they should have but they
should have known something was up with
hr when there was a sign that showed up
in the shield office that was like if
you don't clean out the fridge on
fridays we will execute you
that's how you know there's a problem
that's right we will execute two
extremes
yeah it's the little octopus with a
smiley face
a cute smiley face just like this being
super cute like we'll execute you no big
deal but while shield was dismantled the
dodc lived on in fact we learned that
they were tasked with cleaning up the
blown-up helicarriers and the triskelion
following that battle what is going on
damage control they're still cleaning up
from when captain america took down the
skycraft carriers for no reason which
you know i guess would make sense
considering that's a whole lot of mess a
whole lot of mess to deal with whole lot
of mess and since she was no longer in
charge of all things superhuman it would
make sense that the dodc would grow in
their authority and it's no surprise
that we saw them in spider-man no way
home since they had to deal with
spider-man before we see them cleaning
up after the robbery at queen's
community bank that spider-man stopped
um and got a whole ass convenience store
blown up but luckily the cat survived
i don't know how the cat did that but uh
i would like to think that that cat's a
flurkin hey uh secret flavor knives nine
likes
oh secret [ __ ] confirmed flirkins
have 18 lives that's that's what makes
them special but by the time we see them
in no way home set in 2024 they are with
the cops that arrest peter parker at his
home and so they're no longer just doing
cleanup they're just arresting teenagers
um and ignoring people's rights which on
may and very good teenagers
it's their favorite thing to do this
marvel's the movie thomas marble they
were like oh boy it's the best thing in
the world
another teenager another teenager
they don't arrest them i guess they
bring him in for questioning right yes
but again like they love questioning
teens without a lawyer like you said
miss marvel like when they're invested
they're they're interrogating zoe it's
like teens learn your rights get a
lawyer i don't care what seriously he
says
never speak without a lawyer
why do you want a lawyer i have nothing
to hide exactly unless i'm actually
guilty of something
i'm very aware of your tactics and my
rights
just answer my questions
do not speak to any cop or anybody
without a lawyer like they'll try to
tell you that you have to talk to them
you don't have to talk you don't have to
say [ __ ] stick to the script why did you
pull me over establish that stop i'm not
discussing my day am i being detained or
am i free to go if detained you say i
invoke the fifth
and then you shut the [ __ ] up
do not say anything about a lawyer sorry
this is general just good advice um
anyway
so yeah so they're no longer just doing
cleanup they have investigative
authority now and we saw the stack of
files that agent p cleary had on our boy
pete so
like you saw that stack of files that
ajp clearly had on our boy pete like
they're doing they do their homework on
these people and they also show up at
happy hogan's apartment after jay jonah
jameson tipped them off that's snitch
come and get your snitch i can't even
believe you just i dare you to do your
job as a reporter why you gotta call the
cops your freaking weirdo they only had
a a lizard in their van nothing to see
here please yeah right there i thought i
was in there like no thank you uh
yeah they've been going after spider-man
for a while right like that was probably
their number one target they're like we
had to catch this spider menace like
he's doing all this stuff they've been
watching him for a while yeah it is
interesting to see how much they've
grown in their authority because you're
right empty without shield there's no
one doing this work and we see the you
know in miss marvel they reference the
fbi so like the fbi still exists within
the mcu but they need
i'm sure the fbi's the fbi is busy with
all the other stuff right and they've
set up this dodc they're already dealing
with cleaning up alien tech so they can
be trusted with like the sensitive files
and now it's clear that congress has
given them more authority they're able
to work with the police to get warrants
to do investigations to go they're
basically doing everything shield was
doing before we now know that like
they're really tracking superhumans and
they're on the case about it and looking
into it uh and we'll get into this a
little bit but i think it could play an
important part going forward as they
need to find superhumans
that's very interesting to see where
that goes and now they're interested in
kamala khan as well um like we said
before so
where do we think the dodc will go from
here brandon well i think you know
they're gonna keep having a ton of power
it's clear they've been watching people
um they're putting together these teams
or whatever uh you know eric voss has a
theory i think it might be right that
you know our good boy agent p cleary he
could be like a skrull like
that's how they're tied to sword in a
weird way because like swords doing
other stuff but they they probably each
need to know what's going on and if
swords watch in the skies someone's got
to watch the ground right and that's
where the dog comes in uh so i think
they're they're really looking for the
superhumans a in a way to like get ahead
of them so before they can become
villains they can just be aware of
what's going on but b
because i think things are about to
change and get very interesting and
you're going to have more people with
inherent abilities
their genetics get exified and all of a
sudden they need to know where all these
mutants are and i think that's what the
dlc is gonna do they're gonna find the
mutants
we gotta get these beauties
yeah i think
i think that dodc is eventually going to
be the main force looking for mutants uh
within the mcu i think it's gonna that's
what they're gonna eventually get on to
that would be crazy and then like the
sentinel program could probably come
from the from the department of damage
department that would be bananas to set
up my god
that would be because they have all this
alien technology they can build
sentinels and the sentinels get out of
hand uh yeah i would like to see uh
sentinels that like just move beyond
their their masters right like they're
like we don't even listen to you anymore
you gave us too much ai we're too strong
almost like ultron times two what if
ultron
they start the sentinel program and
ultron infiltrates it because he's been
hiding him
and he he's back surprise [ __ ]
i bet you thought you'd seen the last to
me and it's like ultron's incen and uh
sentinels mixed together
bro either ultron or zola bro like those
two are you know baby oh yeah zola like
he oh my god zola's an opportunist to
the max um but yeah right that would be
a crazy scenario because i can totally
see that happening especially with like
ultron infinity also being a factor in
the mcu now like he could just come back
if like if he loses the gauntlet he's
like all right now i'm just gonna come
in and just um he breaks out of his
little
little little crystal little crystal
ball crystal prism um but yeah um all
anything can happen there i would love
to see that um with right i would love
to see sentinels come from the
department of damage control but
personally i think that the department
of damage control could actually be a
huge factor in the upcoming armor wars
series because we know from spider-man
homecoming oh sure that the damage
control has a huge vault of stuff like
all this armor and technology and like
they're keeping it oh that's a great
point and like why are they like you're
just gonna keep all this stuff here just
uh just to sit and gather dust i don't
think so i think that there's going to
be entities that want to sell that stuff
or just use it for their own ends to
make weapons um to defend their various
countries and whatnot and they probably
inherited uh everything that shield had
fell into the dodc's hands so yeah that
whole vault is probably stuff they've
collected since but all the prior stuff
that shield had i i feel like the
government had less control over shield
i mean they clearly were funding shield
and gave them authority but i think
they've set up the dodc where now the us
government has much more control over
what they do and what they're up to
but i think that's not necessarily a
good thing that the dodc has that tied
has as much time as the government
because like the wrong person gets in
charge we could have a problem we could
have a problem like like captain america
said in civil war agendas can change and
like giving people like totally
especially like government organizations
power in the mcu it's just you're giving
that's just like setting them up for
having a really bad person being charged
and abused that power so
like i feel like that's they're setting
that up for some for some sort of thing
but like i think that it's very likely
that we can see them hunting mutants or
uh just inhumans or or any super powered
people down in the mcu because um the
sokovia accords are still in play like
those are still a factor in the mcu so
like we have to you know round up the
people that aren't following it um so
yeah
round them up but here's the question do
they have more authority than sword our
newest mcu organization
i feel like i feel like on the ground
the dodc probably has more authority
like i feel like sword is still kind of
secretive like they're right you know we
saw we saw with like the one division
hex right they were able to mobilize get
military units out there set up the
perimeter shut down the town do all that
kind of stuff but i feel like the dodc
probably has more like day-to-day
authority they're the ones working with
the police they're the ones like like
you said like keeping files on people
keeping tabs on people yeah i think
sword has more
secret authority like the the big again
the big stuff
like right sword is probably dealing
with the tiamat or whatever they're
dealing with that problem out there and
they probably do have a more authority
overall but we don't know it yet it
hasn't been flexed yet but as for who's
flexing their authority right now it's
the dodc they're really wrong for sure
right now yeah i know i i definitely
agree and and i think that sword just
has a completely different jurisdiction
like completely just like like we're
just monitoring sending in weapons and
stuff like we're not really cleaning
stuff up so like we're just being nerds
up here uh you guys do the real um
policing we're just nerds up in space
yeah um so yeah i feel like it's i don't
really think it's a matter of authority
i think it's just different like things
that people do yeah um well i think it's
how you look at like the cia and the fbi
like the fbi works uh domestically the
cia is not supposed to work domestically
they're supposed to work outside the
country
they maybe have worked domestically and
maybe still are i don't say anything
don't come after me see i said you said
too much brandon
i think it's less big questions
if you never see me again
you didn't do anything i didn't do
anything wrong
but yeah i think it's like sword is like
outward looking and dodc is like inward
looking and that's how it's working
right now
yes that's how i think that makes sense
i think that makes sense that's a really
good observation brandon but that is the
dodc in the mcu in a nutshell i cannot
wait to see what agent cleary is up to
because that man
untrustworthy face i'm sorry
you mean scroll you mean secrets
my goodness if he's part of the secret
invasion we called it well eric called
it first but like my god um i would love
to see it we get to ride his coattails
we'll write eric's yes if he's the
villain of the marvels i would be
shocked
oh my god
he seems really angry about kamala he's
very i don't know he does not seem he
doesn't like teenagers we know that for
sure but he seems like he wants to find
this
i mean he's gonna do that at mt you said
it
stop harassing me on gta online
teenagers it's not fair seriously
[Music]
thank you
that'd be ridiculous um but hey we do
have a brand new latest session shirt up
over at new rockstarsmerch.com it's
called cosmic daydream and it is
inspired by the new miss marvel series
have you heard of it have you watched it
you should because it's freaking the
best and kamala's dad is the most
wholesome man of all time and i better
see many many what a good man um papa
hulks in at cons in the future we we
need to dress up as our favorite uh abu
ah what a what a good what a good man
and like all of our late substation
shirts this shirt is limited edition and
won't be available forever and when you
purchase this latest obsession shirt you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out on inside marvel our miss marvel
after show hosted by eric voss and me mt
the man who says random things and this
is also your last chance to grab our
obi-wan kenobi latest obsession shirt as
well because that's right we have two
lane succession shirts available at the
same time i don't know how we did it we
have the technology it's crazy um it's
insane we are breaking the laws of
physics so head on over to
rocktoastmerch.com right now to buy both
of them and just you know it's an
amazing way to support the channel we
really appreciate it when you do and uh
yeah and before we dive into our
lifesize questions next some words from
the people that help bring big question
to you people like avast avast is a
global leader in cyber security for more
than 30 years entrusted by over 435
million users have you seen that many
people that's a lot of people avast
empowers you with digital safety and
privacy no matter who you are where you
are and how you connect a vast new
all-in-one solution avast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features avast
offers a ton of features such as a pc
speed up which optimizes the background
activity of your apps in order to speed
up your pc and they also have smart scan
which will find and remove viruses and
resolve the most common privacy and
performance issues through an
optimization scan and their
award-winning antivirus will stop
viruses and malware from harming your
machine which is the most important
thing you can do just don't we don't
need viruses we've had enough viruses
it's way too yeah enough viruses protect
those machines down with viruses um a
vast one offers both free and premium
options and i like their data breach
monitoring which lets you know when you
need to change passwords that may have
been compromised and sometimes those
companies don't let you know your
information may have been leaked but a
vast one will which is very nice little
vast thank you about you the best and we
want to thank avast for supporting big
question avast prevents over 1.5 billion
attacks every month and with a vast one
you can confidently take control of your
online world without worrying about
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
so learn more about a vast one at
avast.com again that is avast.com a vast
one thank you for sponsoring this video
you guys are amazing now brandon it is
time for our bite size questions
beat the hulk and this is from blazer
raygun on twitter thank you blazer ah
yes hercules who we're hoping we might
see in thor love and thunder i don't
know we got it
come on we got it come on put the hurt
in there uh but the question is sort of
tough to say right you know as we know
the hulk is pretty much unbeatable as
the more att as the more you attack him
and you make him angry the stronger he
gets the more you hurt him the stronger
he gets you know his body can find
workarounds to like any problems so if
you're gonna beat him you have to kind
of find like a weird little gimmick to
just kind of knock him out right you
never really beat the hulk you just kind
of win that little battle subdue him uh
yeah but hercules himself is also pretty
much unbeatable uh if you don't know
when he was a little baby infant he
sipped some of hera's breast milk so he
has mystical invulnerability uh plus he
is a demigod you know son of zeus uh so
he's like human strength just like the
perseus of jacksonis uh
so he has superhuman strength speed
agility and stamina plus he has an
intense healing factor himself now these
two are both usually good guys but they
have come to blows a couple of times in
the comics you know they always got to
find someone strong for hulk to fight
but the fight is usually interrupted by
someone or like something else happens
or something weird is going on so
they're never like i'm gonna fight you
to the death no i'm gonna fight you to
the death this is just like a little
skirmish
and with mo with most battles against
the hulk you never really beat him uh
you just kind of get lucky and like
knock him out or something happens and
he just get lucky and don't die
yeah yeah and it it seems like in most
of the battles that hulk and hercules
had like hulk ultimately wins but like
you know sometimes it depends on whose
comic it is right uh whatever the story
is going to be is what it kind of
depends on i do think that the hulk can
like heal faster than hercules right we
saw this in the mcu where like he spits
out a tooth uh but banner has a two all
of his teeth when he's back to banner so
it's like the tooth like grows back
instantaneously right it's like
if you we talked about this before on
the big question if you put the hulk
underwater he just like learns how to
breathe water it just hap or you can
just hold his breath forever so it's
like
he just heals too fast whereas i think
hercules maybe takes a little longer to
heal so i think hulk will always have
the advantage there so i think
yes the hercules could beat the hulk but
i think most of the time the hulk's
going to win that fight
i think he's just so powerful well i
feel like um that makes a lot of sense
considering that the mcu version of
hercules wasn't trained by uh phil from
uh the hercules animated movie that's
true who who makes true heroes um so hey
disney owns them both empty we could see
phil in the mcu seriously if oh my god
get bring daddy to vito inexplicably
just put phil
into the mcu
legs on him he'll be fine kevin fogg you
please people will love you forever i
mean people already love you forever but
my god would be hilarious um but yeah
thank you brandon that was that makes a
lot of sense and uh yeah i feel like it
really depends on which book yeah that
people are it's more of a plot question
than like a science question right
whoever has the most plot armor is gonna
win that fight pretty much that's how
marvel rules sometimes but that's comic
books baby that's comic books baby
here's her second question brandon
you're ready for it are you ready i'm
writing now
who is the wealthiest character in the
star wars universe this is from
tryhardist98 on twitter try harder thank
you hope you hopefully you're not trying
too hard um just settle down um blood
pressure doesn't need to elevate that
that high i think we have like a few
main contenders here okay
uh we gotta look at like jabba the hutt
right he basically controlled all of the
large criminal activities allowed to
continue under the rule of the empire
you know he kind of made a deal with the
empire they wiped out all the other huts
and uh jabba was left standing and he
got to run basically any big time crimes
that are going on he's getting a little
taste of it so he's he's pretty powerful
he's pretty rich pretty liquid in his
assets okay uh we also have to consider
count dooku okay
he had a lot of family money uh and he
basically paid for
most of the separatist droid army like
that basically came from his family who
had boosted books
it's true uh and he also
if we remember like uh the jedi uh
uh cephodius sifo diaz right he's the
one who started the clone army
and then dooku kills him and then like
kind of pretends to be him to kind of
continue to oversee the clone program
and i bet like some of his family money
is also going to the clone program i'm
sure you know uh uh uh uh the come on
what are they camino wins camino right
yeah uh i'm sure the camino ends like
every other week were like calling up uh
who they thought was sifo diaz it turned
out to be dukko and they're like hey
yeah sorry we uh we're gonna need some
more money here these guys are really
eating they're eating a lot
dooku's like paying for droids paying
for clones overseeing this whole puppet
war and he's like what is going on here
uh so he's he's pretty rich really uh
but at the end of the day i mean it's
got to be palpatine right he's he's got
the money man
he's the emperor he basically has
unlimited funds he oversees everything
at one point he's controlling both the
senate and the trade federation they're
under his control so he could get money
from whomever he wanted and then once
the empire just takes over he basically
nationalizes all the banks so he
controls the banks now vader had a lot
of wealth too because vader's like a
very high ranking person within the
empire and has wealth but it's only
because it's what palpatine lets him
have right uh plus
palpatine got all of like his former
master darth plagia's money darth
plagueis had a lot of money too a lot of
wealth he just gets all that he kills
his old master and he gets all that
money so it's palpatine baby no one no
one touches palpatine it's kind of and i
don't want to hear about prince seizure
in the comics or in the comments okay
they'll be bringing up the prince cesar
from shadows of the empire like he's
probably rich but he's not canon yet
he's still legends for now so until they
bring him in
we can't consider him palpatine's the
money man like palpatine's so iced out
that he has a big ass kyber crystal
powering his death star so like that's
just that's that's just he's just gotta
afford to rebuild the death star this
guy's got money guys got money right
three times
my god um but yes um thank you brandon
you are a genius of a man and i
appreciate you very much but now it is
time for our boxer scraps the boxes oh
baby put them in the game with a bunch
of scripts
now brandon if you had to run a new
government agency what would you choose
to oversee oh i got the answer for you
mt okay some of you might consider this
part of the fda but we need a new
department just to handle sparkling
water someone has got to get these
sparkling waters under control okay
the flavors have gotten too insane we
gotta we gotta restrict these flavors i
love my pineapple orange sparkling water
delicious that sounds okay that sounds
okay but some of these have got it the
government has got to stop lacroix
coconut flavor it's terrible it's gotta
be it's got to be destroyed we can't
have it anymore is it that bad it's that
bad that's it's that bad empty someone
has got to oversee these sparkling
waters they need to be stopped they're
out of control uh we got to get these
things regulated now i know what you're
saying the fda that's the fda's job no
no they don't they don't do taste
they're just keeping they're just making
sure there's no rats inside of our
sparkling waters i'm gonna be in charge
of taste quality uh and bubble-ness some
of these don't have enough bubbles some
of them are not sparkling enough you
know that's
there needs to be enough like some some
cell to water you just crack it open i'm
like i'm just drinking water like
slightly barely a little bit it's barely
fizzing now we need to put some more i'm
gonna put bubbles in that i'm gonna make
sure tapachiko is available everywhere
because it's not available enough places
it's the best tapachito you don't
sponsor us but please there's a toppo
no one knows how do i say it
but uh that's a good one i like that one
the sparkling water i feel like that
there's there's no rules sparking
water's just running amok so we need
someone to to oversee them it's out of
control it's out of control
but no for me i think i would choose if
i was gonna run a government agency i
would probably oversee the production of
all hollywood sitcoms because back in my
day bro
sitcoms used to be filmed in front of a
live studio audience they don't have
that anymore it's always a laugh track
it's always just like back in the day
you have to earn your jokes you earn
your laughs you don't have to earn your
life something so when i'm in charge i'm
going to make sure every like sitcom is
filmed in front of a live studio
audience if you're going to use a laugh
track no more no more those days are
over i'm sorry i just haven't
passionate about this type of thing
empty i hate to break it to you i think
a lot of those old shows even when they
had live studios audiences they were
still implementing a laugh track because
you can't always dare you
to laugh correctly or at the right time
or maybe they're laughing weird so there
was a live studio audience and maybe
sometimes they were using it but i think
they were still tweaking it but i like
it empty you're gonna make sure there's
no tweaking going on it's not gonna be
tweaking i want relapse
you know as a kid i was always confused
how uh the flintstones had
a studio audit like you could hear
laughing when you watch the flintstones
this is how dumb i was empty i was like
how are they drawing it live i don't
understand
i'm
as fast as they could
and people were like laughing at it i'm
so dumb empty i'm so stupid you're not
done you said huge imagination i like
that man that's totally fine that's
funny like maybe they were just like
playing the flintstones and people were
laughing it's like no they're just
pumping it in that's awesome
it's all movie magic baby or cartoon
magic or flintstone magic from the
prehistoric right i don't know what i'm
saying but that is it for this episode a
big question thank you thank you so much
to brandon off-screen producer brandon
for joining me on this episode follow
him at grin and barrack on twitter you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] and follow new rockstars here
on youtube and when you do hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you got some big questions
of your own share them on our new
rockstars discord server but only if you
are 18 years old and older there's a
link in the description so click on that
and join us today but again thank you
guys so much for watching we love you
guys so much and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you